DID.
AND HILLARY CLINTON HAS BEEN
GONE RATED.
-- GONE RATEED.
>> CONGRESSMAN MARK MEADOWS SAID
THE HOUSE GOP PLANS ON HEARING
TESTIMONY ABOUT THE DOJ'S
INVESTIGATION INTO ALLEGED
WRONGDOING BY THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION.
JOINING ME NOW WITH MORE IS GO
FACT CHAIRMAN DAVID IVELLA,
FORMER CLINTON POLLSTER DOUG
SCHOEN AND FORMER PRESS
SECRETARY FOR VICE PRESIDENT
PENCE MARK LOTTER.
GOOD EVENING EVERYONE.
I FIND, YOU HAVE TO GIVE RUSH
LIMBAUGH HIS DUE, THAT WAS
PRETTY FUNNY.
NOT EVEN GOING ON TALK ABOUT IT
UNTIL WE PROVE THERE WAS A
PRIVATE SERVER IN THE BATHROOM.
BUT I'M GOING TO YOU FIRST,
DOUG.
YOU'RE THE DEMOCRAT AND YOU'RE
ON SET RIGHT NOW.
>> I AM.
>> DOES IVANKA HAVE A PROBLEM
LIKE HILLARY DID?
>> SHE HAS A PROBLEM BUT
CANDIDLY IT'S NOT THE SAME
PROBLEM AS HILLARY.
AND I DON'T THINK PRIVATE
SERVERS SHOULD BE USED.
BUT I THINK RUSH MISSED THE
POINT.
IT'S THAT THE PRIVATE SERVER WAS
USED AND THE PRIVATE ADDRESS,
AND CLASSIFIED INFORMATION AS
FAR AS WE CAN TELL MAY WELL HAVE
GONE TO OUR ENEMIES IN WAYS
THAT --
>> DURING HILLARY.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> WELL THERE'S NO QUESTION.
>> AND THAT TO ME IS FAR MORE
SERIOUS THAN ANYTHING THAT'S
BEEN ALLEGED ANYWHERE ELSE.
>> ONLY ALLEGED BY THE WAY,
DAVID, SIMPLY THAT IVANKA WAS
APPOINTMENTS WITH FAMILY, THE
FAMILY E-MAIL.
BUT WHAT DOUG IS SAYING IS
ACCURATE.
FIRST OF ALL, IVANKA DIDN'T
DELETE ANY E-MAILS, DID SHE?
>> NO, IN FACT REPORTS ARE SHE
ACTUALLY TURNED OVER ALL OF HER
E-MAILS.
AND WHAT WE'RE SEEING HERE,
JUDGE, IS THE DEMOCRATS ARE IN
THE BATTER'S BOX.
THEY'RE GETTING READY FOR
INVESTIGATION AFTER
INVESTIGATION NO THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION -- INTO THE
TRUMPED A BHRGS THE ICING ON THE
CAKE BEING THE EFFORT THAT WOULD
BE MADE TO IMPEACH PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
WHAT THEY COMPARED ON.
DON'T SAY, PEOPLE WILL SAY THIS
IS HYPERBOLE.
WE KNOW WHAT NANCY PELOSI IS
GOING TO DO AS SPEAKER.
SHE DID IT.
SHE PUT HENRY WAXMAN IN CHARGE
OF INVESTIGATIONS DURING THE
BUSH ADMINISTRATION, AND MADE
EVERY MIDLEVEL STAFFER THAT THE
BUSH ADMINISTRATION APOINTS GET
A LAWYER TO DEFEND THEMSELVES
AGAINST FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS WHEN
SHE WAS THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
DURING THE BUSH ADMINISTRATION.
>> AND MARK LOTTER, JIM COMEY
MADE A LOT ABOUT INTENT.
SAYING HILLARY HAD NO INTENT TO
VIOLATE THE LAW EVEN THOUGH
INTENT ISN'T REQUIRED.
HOW DO YOU COMPARE THE INTENT OF
IVANKA AS IT RELATES TO
HILLARY'S SITUATION?
>> WELL, FIRST OFF, THERE CAN BE
NO INTENT.
LET'S REMEMBER, CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION DOES NOT GO OVER
YOUR NORMAL WHITE HOUSE.gov
E-MAIL ACCOUNT.
THERE ARE SPECIAL SERVERERS
REQUIRED FOR THOSE.
SHE HAD TO HAVE THE INTENT IN
HER STAFF TO TAKE IT OFF OF
THOSE SERVERS AND PUT ON IT A
PRIVATE SERVER.
IVANKA IS SENDING A FEW E-MAILS
BACK AND FORTH ABOUT FAMILY,
LOGISTICS, PLANNING, THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS TO GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS WHILE SHE WAS
TRANSITIONING INTO OFFICE.
IS NOT INTENT.
THERE'S NO CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
AND EVERY E-MAIL SHE SENT TO A
GOVERNMENT STAFFER WHILE SHE WAS
TRANSITIONING IN WAS
AUTOMATICALLY CAPTURED BY THE
SYSTEM.
FOR THE PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS.
>> MARK, THAT IS EXACTLY THE
POINT, THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT
RECOGNIZING.
EVERYTHING SHE DID IS CAPTURED
THERE, AND IF IT WERE CLASSIFIED
IT COULDN'T HAVE GONE THROUGH.
I MEAN, WHO ARE WE KIDDING.
>> THERE WAS NO SLEDGE HAMMER TO
DESTROY DEVICES?
>> NONE OF THAT.
>> AND NO 30,000 E-MAILS
DISAPPEARING?
>> NONE OF THAT.
DAVID, THE THING THAT I THINK IS
INTERESTING, IS THAT JEFF
SESSIONS ANNOUNCED LAST YEAR
WHEN THIS WHOLE HOOPLA ABOUT THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION, YOU TOOK A
MONTH TO DECIDE WHETHER THERE
WAS ENOUGH TO LOOK AT IT.
AND HE COMES OUT AND HE SAYS I'M
GOING TO HAVE THE U.S. ATTORNEY
HUBER, I DON'T RECALL WHAT STATE
HE'S FROM, LOOK INTO THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION.
UTAH, OKAY.
HE'S FROM UTAH.
U.S. ATTORNEY.
AND WE HAVEN'T HEARD ANYTHING.
SO MARK MEADOWS, THE HOUSE OF
THE FREEDOM CAUCUS SAYS WHAT'S
GOING ON.
THEY GOT A FEW MORE MONTHS,
THEY'RE GOING TO LOOK INTO IT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> FOR THOSE WHO WATCH THE AMC
DOCUMENTARY ON MONICA LEWINSKY,
THEY'LL THINK BOTH CLINTONS
OUGHT TO BE SERVING TIME IN
JAIL.
TO THIS INVESTIGATION, LET ME
SAY, THERE MAY BE A MORE
PRODUCTION OUT OF MEADOWS, IF HE
WERE TO LOOK AT ALL OF THE MONEY
TOM STIER HAS PUT INTO
DEMOCRATIC ORGANIZATIONS TO
ELECT PEOPLE WHO WANT TO BE --
ALL THEY WANT TO DO IS
INVESTIGATE THIS PRESIDENT, AND
ULTIMATELY TRY TO IMPEACH HIM.
DON'T FORGET WHAT THE CORE OF
STIER'S GRASSROOTS EFFORT IS, TO
IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT.
IN THE FINAL WEEKS THAT MEADOWS
IS CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE AND
CAN CALL ON INVESTIGATIONS, WE
OUGHT TO BE LOOKING INTO THINGS
LIKE THAT.
>> YOU KNOW, WHAT'S INTERESTING,
ALSO, MARK IS THAT MEADOWS, THE
HOUSE FREEDOM KAU KISS, LEAD
E -- CAUCUS IS SAYING HIS
COMMITTEE IS TRYING TO SECURE
TESTIMONY FROM WHISTLE BLOWERS
WHO COULD HAVE HAD MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION.
BUT DO YOU THINK ANYTHING WILL
HAPPEN IN THIS DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE?
I MEAN, THERE IS TALK BY THE
WAY, THAT THE CLINTON GLOBAL
INITIATIVE GOT THEIR 501C3
STATUS FROM NONE OTHER THAN LOIS
LEARNER.
>> I DO HAVE A LOT OF HOPE IN
THIS INVESTIGATION.
BECAUSE THE U.S. ATTORNEY HUBER,
IS SOME ONE OF IMPECCABLE
CREDENTIALS.
IF WE HAVE WHISTLE BLOWERS, THIS
IS NOT JUST ABOUT E-MAIL SERVERS
AND CLASSIFIED INFORMATION AS
IMPORTANT AS THAT IS.
THIS IS BILL CLINTON GETTING A
$500,000 SPEECH FROM RUSSIA AT
THE SAME TIME URANIUM ONE WAS
GOING THROUGH.
OR THE CLINTON FOUNDATION
GETTING $14.5 MILLION IN
MYSTERIOUS DONATIONS FROM
COMPANIES AND GROUPS TIED TO
URANIUM ONE WHILE HILLARY
CLINTON WAS ALLOWING MOST OF OUR
URANIUM TO BE HOLD TO THE
RUSSIANS.
THIS HAS -- SOLD TO THE
THIS HAS SERIOUS NATIONAL
SECURITY POTENTIAL.
>> YOU HAVE TO AGREE THAT THE
APPEARANCE OF PAY FOR PLAY, I
CALLED THE CLINTON FOUNDATION AN
ORGANIZED CRIMINAL ENTERPRISE
PARADING AS A 501C3 CHARITY.
>> I THINK ON THE SIMPLEST
LEVEL, WE OUGHT TO FIND OUT WHAT
HAPPENED.
WHAT DID THE INVESTIGATION SHOW,
WHAT HAVE WE LEARNED, WHERE DO
THINGS STAND.
WE HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW AS
PEOPLE.
>> WHAT HAPPENS IF HUBER COMES
OUT AND SAYS, YOU KNOW WHAT, I'M
A U.S. ATTORNEY, I AIN'T TELLING
YOU.
I'M NOT TELLING YOU, UNTIL MY
INVESTIGATION IS OVER.
THE POLICIES, THE U.S. ATTORNEYS
OFFICE, ARE --
>> FINE, I'D LIKE TO KNOW THAT.
SDPLUD EE LIKE TO KNOW AT LEAST
THEY'RE LOOKING AT IT.
>> THAT THE INVESTIGATION IS
GOING AND WHERE HE STANDS.
WE'VE BEEN GREETED BY JUST RADIO
SILENCE.
I THINK WE HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW,
AS AMERICAN CITIZENS, WHERE
THINGS STAND.
WHATEVER HE WANTS TO SHARE, IS
JUST FINE BY ME.
>> AND DAVID, YOU KNOW, THEY SAY
THAT JIM COMEY WHEN HE WAS THE
UNITED STATES ATTORNEY FOR THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW YORK,
COINCIDENCE, UNBELIEVABLE, WAS
INVOLVED IN LOOKING AT THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION AND THEN IT
WAS ABRUPTLY ENDED.
>> WELL, WRONGDOING AND SELF
SERVING OF THE CLINTONS AND ALL
OF THEIR ALLIES MAY WELL BE
TRUMP JUDGED BY THE CURRENT CROP
OF DEMOCRATS AND WHAT THEY ARE
GOING TO DO TO PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND WHAT THEY'LL TRY TO DO TO
THE COURTS AND EVERY OTHER
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT THEY CAN TO
BRING IN INVESTIGATIONS, BRING
IN IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS,
WHICH WILL BE VERY HARMFUL TO